yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master tacticals Zoltan scholten met VG
let's see what we get um the bogo yeah i
can go Queens Indian also why not let's
try something else um I wanted to play
Bishop a six actually okay Jeff that's
it said check I didn't want to do that
yet at all okay but duck head it cannot
be really bad what does this kind of
this kind of position how do i play here
though hmm with night a six maybe for 93
94 m okay maybe here c5 when therefore
wasn't exactly my expected
now that is to maybe take here and get
95 and should be quite okay let's put it
on c5 now probably rook c8 night be fire
forever something to have in mind hmm i
don't know maybe a six it's a bit
slowish before 94 if the moves the night
have 93 so I have to be have to make
sure that I really have the square i am
ok so Quincy seven I guess Queen d6 this
an idea Maggie I can probably just take
it and play Bishop to c6
don't think this should be a substantial
problem
maybe night yeah night move him I was
thinking about this wasn't totally sure
how to respond to that mmm okay I
probably have to take and now the
question is yeah he's threatening maybe
just night them I'm sorry before and
asking me where I'm going look be eight
before I nitey force giving up is giving
up giving up material and b5 looks looks
wrong I mean takes takes Knight takes
Knight ce4 might be ok because I will
snatch a 2 at the end but I am NOT not
really sure still form yeah how do I
don't really see how to cover him maybe
I have to do that that looks takes takes
rook be 69 f 1 ok
this one okay I because of night and I
cannot be 70 plays rugby 60 yeah okay
yeah okay when I have to do that that's
am at kind of it's not good but just 97
how terrible was that 95 really was for
the problem move Wow there what a bad
game
I mean not it's the wrong way to phrase
it i just played badly that's what i'm
trying to say
yeah it's really no way here to get some
kind of position
hmm am I really busted after 95 I have a
hard time to believe that really I mean
why played them in a very unambitious
manner so I don't think I should be just
lost but hmm weird yeah maybe a six was
really not a great idea but 95 was
irritating yeah of course you can just
do that you know I have no mafia on Rue
k7 he's playing rook t8 there are half a
nonsense what the tourists alike was
reserved yeah let's it's kind of strange
I mean this should just be okay what how
did I how did I got into the get into
this trouble so look here
went here 26 what did i do actually I
took myself yeah maybe this was the
problem yeah yeah yeah that was probably
not a great idea what if i would have a
cavern cover the Queen thing is that in
most cases these types of positions they
are just traded down two to nothing
happening with be against see porn
traded or things like that so white
really doesn't have much to play against
him so I'm really I really don't believe
that it should be something a computer
likes white quite a bit maybe why does
really too quick am in some in some way
check and
hmm yeah I don't know computer gives
white 0.7 which I am not quite sure
about sure that it doesn't look eerily
it's not it's not looking like an equal
position that sets clear chan maybe not
a six maybe not a six you know I should
have gone here that's better than I was
always thinking about Quincy 7 for some
reason this is what I should do of
course yeah that's much better night v5
now is not leading to anywhere and the
big differences if he goes for a trade
now I really should be ok and now I
don't have this weakness that if I get
in King to a7 is just totally equal it's
totally equal him Queen d6 is also not a
good move i think you should try to keep
things like on the board then this or
rook c8 through the other rogue I mean
and not just not sure about it this is
much better I am this yeah this is the
sole this this is all based on on the
wrong idea that has somehow want to go
Queen c7 and Quincy 7 is there obviously
not good and I wanted to put the Queen
down and because I wanted to do that i
played a six but I didn't really pay so
much attention to the weekend b6 porn
and this this finally cost the game
quite interesting quite interesting so I
just have to do this
hmm that's interesting it's really only
thinking about putting the Queen on c7
and I can just go here of course okay
yeah so I guess some lesson learned you
can just put the Queen here yeah often
you have this position when there's a
bishop still only seven so maybe I'm
didn't have this this on the radar so
the same okay thanks for watching